an alarming new study shows countries
are releasing a record amount of
greenhouse gases that contribute to
global warming the UN secretary-general
said this we are in deep trouble with
climate change more than 37 billion tons
of planet warming emissions are expected
to be released into the atmosphere in
2018 and that's roughly 100,000 times
the weight of New York's Empire State
Building that's a lot China is the
largest carbon emitter in the world the
US by the way is number two and Tracey's
shows us the effects of dangerous air in
Beijing good morning it's a rare blue
sky day here in Beijing but generally
during the winter months it's so
polluted that most of us are walking
around with one of these masks on our
face and using sensors like this to
constantly check the air quality inside
our homes and our offices and that's
because Chinese cities often look like
this toxic clouds of pollution block out
the Sun and make simply breathing in
cities like Beijing hazardous for your
health now a lot of the carbon emissions
here are from burning coal which not
only fuels much of China's manufacturing
economy but also heats people's homes in
the winter china produces 27% of the
world's global emissions and they are
expected to rise 4.7 percent this year
the u.s. is the world's second worst
polluter accounting for 15% of global
emissions the European Union and India
round out the top 4 oil demand has risen
for five years in a row we do have more
efficient cars than we used to have but
around the world more people are driving
and they're driving for their distances
for CBS this morning Ben Tracy Beijing
this is the third major recent report to
raise the alarm about global warming
world leaders are meeting in Poland and
they're trying to figure out how to keep
temperatures from rising more than 3.6
degrees Fahrenheit above pre-industrial
levels we need to pay attention to this
this is very very serious you know and
getting worse I know and I keep thinking
certainly this is going to be the major
issue for our children's generation with
rising sea levels rising temperatures
all of it droughts which affect
agricultural prices it's a real thing US
policy is not really addressing that
issue